our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater
than what divides us and this morning a
boarding school in washington d.c that's
helping at-risk children
stay safe and thrive at monument academy
the head of school is a driving force
in fighting homelessness he's pushed to
keep the doors open
even during the pandemic jeff begaye has
been following this story for
more than nine months jeff good morning
to you what's going on at that school
well good morning classes are about to
get underway here any minute now this is
a school tony that reopened
last month after being shut down because
of the pandemic and the
10 percent of the student body that came
back to classes well they were the ones
who are having the hardest time with
remote learning well now
they have a place to learn and live
after nearly seven months monument
academy
opened its doors again parents brought
their children back to a school
welcome kamai that kamari says is a
refuge
there's a whole lot of people out there
getting shot that's little kids
kamari is one of seven kids his mother
raises alone while working
multiple jobs is school
an escape for you yes in what ways
like taking a little bit off my mom's
plate like
she don't have to deal with another
child
to spend more money than she has to
gomari's struggles are common for these
students
the majority of the student body at the
starter school is at risk
on medication or they have special needs
the school ceo jeffrey grant says the
academy serves students who need
more than just an education we're able
to support the parents by ensuring that
their most
precious assets are fed are housed
are clothed are nurtured are provided
opportunities to become
successful community members all of that
was put on hold during the pandemic
on the earth standing upside down right
now you all realize that we first
visited the school in february but they
don't feel
before the pandemic began right
at the time the students lived here
under supervision
in apartment-like student life homes
how has your life changed since you've
been in a school
they feed us and vote for my head
get a good education here good morning
the pandemic could be the school's
greatest challenge to date
we require additional funding so that we
can give them the wrap-around services
the emotional support the traditional
children's service we will have a great
fundraiser in the springtime
to close that gap that we have to close
each and every year
the pandemic shut that down
it's too early to tell how successful
bringing these students back into the
building will be
trying to get money they are still
virtual learning with their laptops and
teachers are not
yet allowed to teach in classrooms here
but the upside this is a safe space for
students like crystal you just realize
when it's gone like were you not in
school how much you missed school
and how much it helped you throughout
the years
for grant the mission is to keep the
doors open
to protect the students who need it most
we're bringing them into an environment
seven days a week
for seven weeks so that they can have
that stability
they're not going outside and being
exposed to crime
abuse that's what we're here to do and
that's what we're going to do i'm
checking in all right we'll be back
all right so school gets out here this
afternoon and then the students will be
allowed to go home for
thanksgiving break the goal of the
program is to expand the number of
students who are going
to the school in the coming weeks and
months but all of that gail is dependent
on
the pandemic of course yeah this
pandemic has changed everything thank
you so much jeff
but you know you've got a special place
when the kids want to stay at school
they don't want to leave seven days a
week
because it's giving them a safe space
nothing more important than that
bravo to you jeffrey grant need more of
you